How did you know the
mighty ducks would win?
Luck and reinforcement learning hello
world it Saroj and sports betting.
It's a popular pastime for many and a
great use case for an important concept
known as dynamic programming
that I'll discuss in this video.
We know that reinforcement learning is
the subfield of machine learning that
focuses on goal oriented algorithms
that involve time delayed label's called
rewards.
And we've also learned that the standard
way to represent this problem of an AI
trying to maximize its rewards in a time
based environment setting is by using
the mathematical framework known
as a Mark Cobb decision process.
Now let's use these concepts to help
us frame our problem of betting on the
winning hockey team.
Assume that we are a
professional sports gambler,
let's call ourselves JK Rowling Endo and
our career is to make money by betting
on whether or not a certain
hockey team will win a game.
And there's a series of these games that
will occur sequentially that are all
apart of a tournament.
Our goal is to make 100 US dollars by
successfully betting on the winning team.
What can I say?
We dream big for each game.
There are only two possible outcomes.
Either are chosen,
team wins or they lose.
We'll place a bet on that team at the
start of the game and if they do win,
we will win the same amount to that.
We bet.
Otherwise the opposite will happen
and we'll lose all the money. We bet.
Let's also make one fundamental
assumption here that we'll touch on later.
We'll assume that the home
team will win 40% of the time,
no matter who the home team is.
So for every game we have to decide how
much of our money we wanted to put at
stake in the context of
reinforcement learning.
Then we can consider this a
Mark Cobb decision process.
The state would be how much
money we have at any given point.
The actions are steaks or
bets that we would place.
The reward is going to be zero on all
transitions except those in which we reach
our goal.
Then it's plus one.
What we'll want to then
learn is an optimal policy.
Our policy will be a mapping between
levels of capital we have to how much we
should bet the optimal policies should
then maximize the probability of reaching
our goal,
which is to make $100 and remember we
are making an assumption here that the
home team will win 40% of the time.
So we can set p the probability of the
home team winning to 0.4 since P is
known, the entire problem space
is known and can that be solved?
Meaning we have a complete
model of this environment.
That's definitely not always the case.
But for this introductory example,
it will be to make our problem easier and
it's good practice to denote any other
characteristics of our mark comm decision
process that we can find like the fact
that it can be considered episodic,
meaning it lasts a finite amount of
time when the game ends rather than
continuous.
So how do we find this mythical Unicorn
function known as the optimal policy?
Well. If we look back at
the Bible of RL called Rl,
an introduction by sudden and Barto in
chapter four will come upon a pretty
useful definition.
The term dynamic programming refers to
a collection of algorithms that can be
used to compute optimal policies given
a perfect model of the environment as a
mark Haub decision process.
That's perfect for us.
Since we already know the
transition probabilities,
which indicates the probability of a
change from state s to the next state and
we've got a reward function.
Dynamic programming is a way of
breaking down complex problems into sub
problems.
We solve the sub problems,
then combine the solutions to those sub
problems to solve the larger problem.
There are many different types of DP
techniques and it's actually used in many
real world applications
like bio informatics,
scheduling and routing algorithms.
The specific dynamic programming algorithm
will use in this example to solve our
problem is called value iteration.
It turns out that any optimal policy
can be subdivided into two components,
an optimal first action followed by
an optimal policy from the next state.
If our first action is optimal and after
that we follow an optimal policy from
where we end up,
then we can conclude that the
overall behavior is optimal.
These rules can be formalized by what's
called the principle of optimality.
A theorem invented by the mathematician,
Richard Bellman, decades ago.
It states that a policy achieves the
optimal value from state s if and only if
for any next state reachable from s our
policy achieves the optimal value from
state s so we can essentially break
down the description of what it means to
have an optimal policy in terms of finding
the optimal policy from all states.
We could end up in after that,
we just need to do a one step look ahead
and discern what the best first action
we could have taken his.
That's the principle of
optimality applied to policies.
So notice this somewhat
counterintuitive intermediate step here.
Before we can compute the optimal policy,
we need to compute the optimal action
value function called Kyu and there's a
great formula that expresses this
very well. Can you guess what it is?
We can express the value of any state as
a some of the immediate reward plus the
value of the next date.
This expression is popularly
called a bellman equation.
It will help estimate the best action to
take using the value for a given state
in order to find the optimal policy.
So if we know the solution
to this sub problem,
like the optimal value
function from the next state,
then the value function given this states
can be found by a one step look ahead.
Using the bellman equation in
the value iteration algorithm,
we will iteratively apply the bellman
equation to compute the optimal value
function. One Way to think about this
formula is that from a given state,
there are many possible actions so we
can accumulate the values for how much
each action would get in terms of expected
value and just assign the value of
the state to that of the action
which return the highest value.
We've basically taken the bellman equation
and turned it into an update rule.
The Algorithm initializes via vests
with arbitrary random values than it
repeatedly updates the state
action pair called queue.
And the [inaudible] of s
values until they converge.
Value Iteration is guaranteed to
converge on the optimal values.
Guaranteed sounds pretty great, doesn't
it? Especially when money is involved,
but let's take a closer look here in the
context of our sports betting problem,
where the state is,
how much money we have,
the actions are the states and the
reward is zero on all transitions except
those in which we reach our goal.
When it is plus one we can try
and compute the optimal policy.
The state value function will give the
probability of winning from each state.
A policy is a mapping from levels of
capital to steaks and the optimal policy
maximizes the probability
of reaching the goal.
The reason we can use value iteration is
because of the value of p four me four
is known.
If we were to graph out the
value estimates versus the
amount of capital we have,
we'd see how the value function
changes over successive sweeps of value
iteration and the final policy is found
for the case of p equals 0.4 we can then
use that policy to make the
most likely bets in the future.
Notice however,
that we need that value of p to compute
the optimal policy using value iteration
in general, even though dynamic
programming is very useful,
it does have its limitations.
We need a perfect environment model in
the form of a Mark Cobb decision process
to do it and it's very
computationally expensive.
Solving the bellman equation is a brute
force job we're doing by trying out
every possible action. We
could do it every state. If
we tried to do this for say,
a game of chess,
we'd need computing power that would
make Google's global supercomputer looked
like a super Nintendo system.
Still,
it's a useful thought exercise and it is
used in many real world situations that
don't require massive amounts of compute.
Also,
did you notice something?
We had that intermediate step where we
computed the optimal value function to
compute the optimal policy,
but what if we just skip that intermediate
step and just computed the optimal
policy directly? What type of
algorithms should we use for that?
That's the topic for the next video.
Three points to remember
from this video though,
dynamic programming refers
to the collection of
algorithms that can be used to
compute optimal policies given a
perfect model of the environment.
Value Iteration is a type of dynamic
programming algorithm that computes the
optimal value function,
and consequently,
the optimal policy and dynamic programming
is useful but limited because it
requires a perfect environment model
and is computationally expensive.
I am proud of you for making it here.
Hit subscribe and your enemies
will become your friends. For now,
I'm going to compute the optimal
life policy, so thanks for watching.